hey there everyone welcome to california
i'm about to show you a moon tree
that's right a moon tree
now there are moon trees all over the
world not just here
they're mainly in the united states and
another place you can find them is the
good state of alabama
that's where my friend destin lives
so i asked him if he'd also help me out
in
what should we call this operation moon
tree roll tad brady i am more than
willing to take on this assignment from
you
i am pulling up next to the us space and
rocket center right now
we are about to go inside and check out
some apollo stuff and talk about moon
trees okay so what exactly is a moon
tree well a moon tree is a tree
grown from seeds that were taken to the
moon
seeds taken to the moon basically about
500 seeds were taken to the moon by an
astronaut called stuart rooser
he was the command module pilot of
apollo 14.
now before he was an astronaut rusev was
what's called a smoke jumper
smoke jumpers parachute firefighters
one answer to the problem of fire in
remote roadless areas so he had an
association with trees and he was asked
if he'd take these seeds on his voyage
to the moon
he agreed okay check it out this is the
saturn v
this is what took the seeds to the moon
we're gonna go to the end of the museum
here and see if we can look at the
apollo capsule
which i don't know if the seeds were
actually in there or not at some point
but uh i guess it would have to if it
returned to earth come on let's go check
it out
all right so
this is the apollo 16 command module so
this is not apollo 14
which is what the seeds were actually
taken on but still the apollo program
was stinking awesome here's a moon rock
by the way stuart roosa didn't actually
walk on the moon that was alan shepard
and edgar mitchell rooseve stayed above
in the command module called kitty hawk
basically orbiting the moon waiting for
his buddies to come back
he didn't mess around while he was up
there though he had a lot to do he
actually took a lot of photos of the
moon and so while the guys were down on
the surface of the moon
these seeds were going around the moon
right there so the seeds didn't actually
touch down on the moon but they did go
around the moon
after that
they went back up they rendezvoused and
then they came all the way back
and that's when the seeds went to
mississippi which is where they started
to sprout once they were sprouted they
got handed out all over the nation even
to other countries and we're going to go
try to find one of those trees right now
so my moon tree is one of these here
it's actually surprising sort of how
hidden away it is you'd think it'd be
out on grand display really important
but this one's
well it's not easy to find if you don't
know what you're looking for now
unfortunately
there were seven here at the space and
rocket center but in the 80s they died
oh well i guess that's bound to happen
to some of the trees
now where are we
it's around here somewhere i tell you
what this is hard work making these
educational youtube videos
no messing around okay we don't know
exactly where the trees were planted it
was somewhere here at the space and
rocket center so in order to figure out
what the whole ground looks like
we're running space shot
oh goodness okay
somewhere over there the trees were
playing somewhere over there not really
sure where
did you like that yeah
what's your name hannah hannah didn't
like it i loved it i thought it was
great oh the seeds were up there they
went to the moon they came back they
were planted somewhere over here and
they died but we're gonna go see if we
can find a tree that actually survived
there was no countdown or anything
so we're gonna go to birmingham
botanical gardens and see if we can find
the only one that i'm aware of here in
the state
let's go check it out
keep the glasses on
lunch commit
we have liftoff
three minutes past the hour
this is it
this is my moon tree
if you don't believe me
have a look at this surprisingly
unimpressive little sign hidden away
down here
coast redwood sequoia sepperverenz
moon tree in quotation marks the seed
from which this tree sprang was taken to
the moon how's it going
doing good we're looking for the moon
tree
moving tree let me show you okay let's
go find the moon tree oh there's a guy
in in england his name is brady and he
has an educational youtube channel and
he's making a video about moon trees and
he sent me up here oh to find the moon
tree so could i get seeds from this tree
and have a second generation is that how
that works
because we've done it before we've
actually collected seed and we sent it
to a michigan arboretum so that leads
nicely to the issue of second generation
moon trees i'm sure you can figure out
what they are
these are the sons and daughters of
original moon trees or first generation
moon trees just take the seeds plant
them somewhere else
and it sounds to me like destin's lining
himself up for a second generation moon
tree in his backyard in alabama can we
climb in there and see if we can find an
elite i mean a seed all right let's go
come on let's go mr taylor said we could
do you know what a moon tree is no what
would you guess a moon tree is
a moon tree a moon tree
their branches are shaped in a crescent
oh that's a good guess
it's not right but it's a good guess no
it was grown from seeds that were taken
to the moon by astronauts oh
wow no that i wouldn't have thought of
interesting
yeah
do you see any
sycamore sea pods i don't know what they
look like do you so destin's moon tree
that's a sycamore
mine here
this is a redwood there were three other
types sweetgums furs and pines
they're your moon trees that's the five
types of seeds that stuart roosa took to
the moon i'm gonna touch the bark
so this tree
came from a seed
that went to space not only did it go to
space
it went around the moon
there you go dustin
i'll send you those bad boys brady we're
not gonna find any seeds they keep it
too clean around here it looks like they
trimmed it at one point in time
man that thing is big isn't it look at
that there's the moon
and there's the moon tree
moon
moon tree
moon
moon tree so what i think is cool about
moon trees is that
that means that seeds are completely
transportable like it's a little unit of
life that goes dormant
and you can do whatever you want with it
and it's still gonna work
rooser mitchell and shepard they've all
died now in fact apollo 14 is the first
mission for which all three astronauts
have passed away
so it's somehow fitting that they're the
ones that have left us with this legacy
of apollo
not a statue
not a stone or a metal monument
but something living and through second
generation moon trees and maybe third
fourth fifth generation moon trees a way
that we can always remember
one of humankind's greatest
accomplishments
if you've never seen destin's youtube
channel smarter every day
i'm amazed you haven't but you really
should it's not only one of the best
educational channels on youtube it's one
of the best channels on youtube full
stop make sure you check it out links
are on the screen description all the
usual places
right i was i was thinking if they took
eggs to the moon and then brought the
eggs back and hatched them you could
have moon chickens
but they wouldn't have big legs so you
couldn't eat them
i don't know yeah you could just have
them as a pet
i have a moon chicken